foreign
it was like any other peaceful afternoon
in my home in 2004.
cartoons were blaring kids were running
around the house yelling loudly
VeggieTales on 100.
well maybe not so peaceful
but for a young mother it was perfect
it was like music to my ears
but then it was a loud knock at the door
that just disrupted that laughter and my
kids yelled out to me Mommy
the police are at the door
and as I walked up to talk to the police
it's almost like I walked into the
Charlie Brown movie do y'all remember
the teacher when she just like
because the words were just getting lost
and I didn't know what was going on
and I just snapped out of it and I was
like oh
I'm about to be arrested
I was about to be arrested because two
months prior I had wrote a check for 87
and 26 Cents for groceries
and that check had bounced
and let me be clear there's a thing
called prosecutional uh discretion
meaning the district attorney did not
have to prosecute me but they did
and totally against my fashion statement
right the police
placed these silver bracelets
on my arms handcuffs
and that day they handcuffed me in front
of my babies
it took me to jail
you know luckily I was able to come home
pretty quickly because it was my first
defense and I promised the first thing I
did when I got home I borrowed some
money so I could pay that check back and
then I had to borrow some more money to
pay back the fees for getting arrested
and going to jail because of course I
was loading the cash because I was this
young mom with four kids bouncing 87
checks
and I just knew
that
that chapter of my life was closed
except it wasn't because see that arrest
and that conviction it remained on my
record
and at that moment I realized that my
true sentence had just begun because you
know what I was no longer allowed to
volunteer at my children's school I
could no longer rent where I want to
rent because it is legal
for landlords to discriminate against a
person with a record I even face
barriers trying to go to college
and still to this day
I am excluded from certain
certifications and occupational license
all I could keep asking myself
damn
what will my senses end
and sadly I am not alone there are more
than 100
million Americans
that is one in three people who have an
arrest or conviction
on their record
and get this more than 94 of employers
more than 90 percent of landlords and 72
percent of colleges and universities use
background checks to screen out
applicants
making it harder for millions of
Americans to access jobs housing and
education
it's like damn how's that how am I
supposed to get out and do better if no
one will rent to me no one will hire me
and I can't even go to school
but I believe I truly believe that
America is a a nation of Second Chances
and I say that because just about every
state has laws on the books that allow a
person to get their record cleared once
they're eligible
and right now there are more than 30
million people who are eligible to get
the record cleared
but this is where it gets a little crazy
less than 10 percent of those people
actually get it done
either they don't know about it or if
they do the process is so bureaucratic
costly and full of red tape
for instance in some states people have
to wait just about five to ten years
just to even qualify to get the record
cleared
then you have to appear in person to
petition that means you need to take
time off work and let's be let's keep it
real
it was hard enough to find a job in the
first place you have to file a mountain
of paperwork and then sometimes you have
to pay processing fees up to 500 per
charge
and then you if you're smart you may
want to just get a lawyer to help you
navigate that whole process
so that means if your crime was being
poor like mine
record clearance is not even accessible
I'm looking at some of your faces
you're seeing really bummed out and
discouraged
but I promise I didn't come all the way
to Vancouver Ted to tell you bad news
I got some good news
This Record clearance problem is
solvable and it's fixable and we're
doing a damn thing and the key is
automatic record clearance for those who
are eligible we are removing all that
red tape and we do that by passing what
we call Clean Slate laws and what that
is is laws that say once a person has
remained crime free for a set period of
time and they're eligible
set period of time by the state's
definition we might remain a crime free
that their record is automatically
cleared
red tape cut
and this is the beautiful thing about it
we shift the burden from the person who
made the mistake to the system that
tries to trap them in that mistake
foreign
policies are working and I know that
because I am the proud CEO of the Clean
Slate initiative and in just the last
three years we've been able to help Six
States pass Clean Slate laws I'm talking
about red States blue States and even
purple States okay
that that has resulted in three million
people getting their records cleared
that's millions of people who no longer
have to walk around with stigma and
shame attached to their name
I even one time y'all met this older
fellow I mean he was in his 80s but he
was a fragile 80 year old man
I met him in Miami Florida at an
expungement clinic and I could not
fathom why this man was there
he was there to get his record cleared
and all I could think about was he
wasn't there to get a job
find housing
he didn't want to die being defined by
his record
Clean Slate laws will either help people
like him too
it's like with a stroke of a Governor's
pen we were able to unlock dreams for
Millions
and because of this audacious project
we're on a pathway to make automatic
record clearance in reality
a rally in all 50 states we're building
a pathway that automatic record
clearance is a reality in all 50 states
that will unlock second chances for
additional 14 million people
I just want to leave you all with this
and I even invite some of you to close
your eyes when I ask you this
because it's really important
I want you to think about all the second
chances that you've received
whether it was from your teachers
your parents your community
even your kids
think about what that felt like
think about what that did for you
I know for me
it was able it enabled me to be able to
change like turn my pain into purpose it
enables me to be able to walk into a
room and feel seen not as damaged goods
but as untapped potential
foreign that is the power of a second
chance
that is the power
of a clean slate
and there's no greater gift than that
thank you foreign